is crazy to read about World War II
before they knew what was going on nuts
in one of one of the magazines they're
like the U.S sent defensive machinery
and equipment to the UK to prevent an
invasion and it basically shows the
armaments for D-Day like we now know the
U.S was sending weapons so they could
storm the beaches of Normandy back then
it was reported that they were just
defending the UK Oh you mean the news
was lying to people
well I mean look I don't expect them to
be alike we're going to invade the whole
thing was subterfuge played on the
Germans essentially so they didn't know
when they were coming or where they're
coming from it really is these magazines
are incredible to like read history in
the perspective of the day with no
foreknowledge
having the gift of hindsight to read
like it's it's just a crazy thing to
read someone a journalist be so wrong
about it it's part of why we need to
preserve our data